كثيرا ما نرى اقتحام البيوت الفلسطينيه
قليلا ما نعرف حجم الاجرام الذي يقع خلال
الاقتحام جريمه جديده تتجاوز كل الاعراف
الاخلاقيه والقوانين العسكريه ارتكبتها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فضفت الغربيه
المحتله فلم تكتفي بانتهاك حرمات البيوت
بل تجاوزتها الى الخطوط الحمر
في الخبر الفضيحه الذي نشرتها اريس مع
منظمه المعنيه بحقوق الانسان فان 50 جنديا
اسرائيليا اقتحموا فجر احد ايام شهر تموز
يوليو الفائت منزل عائله فلسطينيه من سته
وعشرين فردا في مدينه الخليل داخل المنزل
بعد تحطيمه اتجهت مجندتان صوب خمس سيدات
فلسطينيات من الاسره واجبرناهن على خلع
ملابسهن والسير عاريات امام اولادهن تحت
تهديد الكلاب البوليسيه المفترسه وقالت
احدى الضحايا ان الكلب اقترب منهن الى حد
مخيف ولم يكتفوا بذلك فقد اثبتوا انهم
لصوص ارض ومال فسرقوا مصاغا ذهبيا واموالا
من داخل المنزل اكثر من ذلك تقول منظمه
بيت سلم ان الواقعه ليست وحيده بل جزءا من
سلسله وقائع يجري فيها التنكيل بسيدات
الفلسطينيات ومحاوله اهانتهن واذلالهن
الخبر كان له وقع الصاعقه على فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي توعدت قوات
الاحتلال بالثار مثل ما وصفت السلطه
الفلسطينيه الواقعه بانها امر فظيع ومخزن
واثار الحدث عاصفه من الغضب والشجب داخل
فلسطين وخارجها بينما لم يصدر تعليق عن
جيش الاحتلال كان الفلسطينيون وحدهم
يعرفون ان ما جرى لا يمر دون عقاب وانهم
لا يسكتون عن المس بالارض وقبلها العرض